Sonja,
has your husband ever been rushing out
the door and he's wanted to shave his
back, but he didn't have the time.
He didn't have the time to do it.
Shave his back. I am uncomfortable talking
about my husband's grooming habits.
Well, that's a yes.
This is the cool thing.
There's a device called the back blade
2.0 it's the ultimate man grooming tool
and it would allow your
husband, if he shaved his back,
he could do it in minutes,
so if you had an appointment or someplace
he had to be and wanted to shave his
back. Done. Know what I'm
saying? It offers a clean,
close shave more so than other
bodily groomers and get this,
the unique patented dry glide blades.
It allows him to shave with or without
shaving cream and water. That's great.
That really cuts down on the time because
how do you put shaving cream on your
back? Oh, trust me. You have to get other
men involved. That's what I've done.
You meet people though.
Anyway, this Christmas,
tell your man to ditch that
ugly Christmas sweater,
which I guess refers to his body
hair the heck I've never anyway.
And get him a back blade 2.0 available
at [inaudible] dot com that's B a k B a l
a d.com.
They forced me to spell.
Obviously everybody knows now
that you cannot drink and drive.
There are probably people that think
it's okay to drive when you're stoned.
They just think, well, I'll
probably just drive a little slower.
But that's not the case. Your
reaction time is affected. Um,
when you're high and you're
putting yourself in danger,
you're putting other people in danger.
So just a quick no joking around message,
don't kid yourself. If you've
been using marijuana in any form,
do not get behind the wheel.
Um, if you feel different,
you actually drive different. It's just
that simple. And this is something I'm,
I'm very serious about.
If you drive high,
you're going to get a Dui
and much scary than that.
You can end up really hurting
someone, uh, yourself included.
So just a reminder.
Hi,
my name is Nick Offerman
and my name is Megan Mullally.
Hmm.
And I,
I dunno about you,
but I feel ambivalent about
being Conan O'Brien's friend.
I felt really good about it.
I hope to,
hey,
welcome to Conan O'brien needs a friend.
This is the podcast where I Conan talk
to people I've interviewed over the years
on my TV job.
Try and figure
out what's really the deal with us.
Are we friends? He said all fake.
What's really happening? And I'm
joined in this quest, if you will,
by a among Saskia and my
assistant and a podcast.
Extraordinary Ian, if that's even
a word. Matt Gorley. Hi. Okay.
And today I'm talking to two
of my favorite people ever.
I absolutely adore them.
Megan Mullally and nick off.
I do think of all the
people I've talked to,
we are legitimate legitimately friends.
We have gone out socially many times.
What was that noise you made?
You made a noise. It was, it was
involuntary. What the hell was it?
You seem skeptical about this whole thing.
Let's just,
let's just keep chatting.
You were saying were we've
gone out many times. Several,
I wouldn't say Manny, we've
gone out many times. Okay.
We got many times. Uh,
going back to, I mean years,
years and years and years,
15 years.
I absolutely love you guys. I love
you individually. And I'm saying this,
this isn't even a comedy riff,
but as a United force,
you're greater than uh, your, your
separate parts. Does that make sense?
You haven't seen all of my separate parts,
so you might revise that.
Oh my God, she's taking off her
clothes right now and I do revise that.
She's good. She's got a great, uh,
she's got a great set of talents.
Now. I, I made an incorrect assumption.
I didn't realize this was
a sincere conversation.
It isn't really what I like to do is
when you go insincere, I go sincere.
I startle you and,
and then you start to get to see her
and then I slam you with insincerity.
Freaking loves you.
He considers you a king among men.
And that's not a chat. It's nice.
I, I will lie in eyes. You at
any given opportunity, he does.
Well that's right.
Lion eyes or you want to hear that a
lot anymore when you first hear it,
it makes it the word sounds like it
means I will tear you apart like Elian as
opposed to I will hold you in high regard.
Right.
I will render you the king of any
given jungle. That's so nice of you.
Only is this big words when he's being
interviewed. But at home he's just like,
Ugh,
like cake.
There's no better way to say really.
There's no,
uh, I'm gonna say this. I don't want
to embarrass your both embarrass you,
but you're both a
supremely talented people,
but you're also real human beings.
You're nice, good ethical people.
I've that demonstrated in
private many, many, many times.
And I admire that about you both. I think
that. Thank you. That's very, very nice.
He was [inaudible] that's sincere.
I feel like the reason that, um,
we have had so many double dates with
you and you're beautiful and even killed
wife Liza as that,
whereas we have similarities in that
department as couples, as couples.
But I will say there are
differences which is um,
lies and I are both a little over
pressed you to our sexual animals.
Yeah,
I let it hang out.
I mean we have talked about this before
but you are quite open about the fact
that your beast like and I mean that as
a compliment or you mean your anal not
anal. No, I didn't mean ane.
Okay. Why did you go to angel?
Well beastiality in the Bible I
think is referring to and the,
but I didn't,
I said beast like beastiality
we'll get to that and listen.
Maybe that's something you guys
are into. I don't know. And I've,
and I've never in my life,
he just said
never in my life have I said
I want to read about butt sex.
Whereas my Bible just
never occurred to me.
Well Old Testament,
New Testament Leviticus specifically,
that's where all the good
stuff is. Okay. Thank you.
The Leviticus is the home of abominations.
Okay.
So,
but you too,
I mean you've told me personally stories
about the two of you being in nature in
the woods fornicating and
that it's this beautiful act.
And that animals are, are watching
you in Congress. Can I use that term?
Coyotes. Coyotes. Coyotes
watched you have sex.
Where was this?
It was in a park and cold water.
Cold Water Canyon here in Los
Angeles. So we were like, uh,
like on a beautiful camping trip. We are
literally in the middle of the city. Oh.
So anyone could have opened their back
door seeing you two going at it and
thrown cold water on you. Right.
You were in an almost an urban area,
but you found a sort of magical,
we found the wooded area,
a little corner,
a secluded area.
It was early on and it,
uh,
I feel like so many of the
pleasures in our marriage, uh,
have been cruise directed by Megan.
And this was no exception. Uh,
it was after our play, one night
we went to a fancy grocery store,
which was a new thing for me and got a
baguette and cheeses and a bottle of Nice
wine and, and she, she knew
the park. Uh, she may have
been there before me,
wasn't my first coyote.
Okay.
That or user like she's back
in the squirrels are like,
oh,
this guy does.
Uh, [inaudible]. And I'll
be honest, I'd have been,
I'm very ashamed of my own
body and I'm not comfortable.
I don't think I'd be naked
out in the world ever.
I won't take my clothes off
from my doctor. And then you to,
you must've seen in nick that he was
capable of shedding his clothes and
becoming almost this,
this naked Werewolf. Yeah.
Could commune with nature and
satisfy your most base urgent.
Yeah. That's one thing that I, I liked
about nick is that he's a really nice guy,
but he's also sort of like a demonic,
you know,
serial killer.
So there's both sides of that because
there's somebody too nice all the time.
You just want to punch him in
the face in the morning. Yeah.
And then the guys that are
really bad or bad. Yeah.
He strikes a balance.
Yeah.
I get a, um, Seder vibe
from you, nick. You know,
it was the old half man,
half goat with,
with a big genitals that that plays a
fight for and goes through the woods and
only wants to have sex
constantly and lives for today.
That's what I get partially from you
let you know when I first met nick,
I had only ever dated these
really like Sperry skinny,
boyish, kind of hairless and
draw basically gay guys. Yeah.
You know,
up until the end you are describing me.
Yes.
Up until the aunt and I'm to go ahead.
And then I met nick and I didn't really
know what to make of it all and he at
the time, back then, that
was in 2000 he was like,
I take like 40 pounds
heavier. Sure. He was a big,
big man and he was bald for the play.
He shaved his head for the plan.
He had a mustache and it wasn't that cute.
I mean there's a lot of back hair.
I remember
when I first met you too,
it was a Saturday night live reunion show.
I had not met you and you came
up and you introduce me to nick.
And Nick was wearing a big leather biker
jacket and he had a big chain hanging
off and everyone else there was, you
know, prince was there and you know,
in sync. And it was just this
ridiculous gathering of, uh, of,
of people that were all dressed in their
finery, the grapes, all the grades. Um,
I think boys to men were present.
The Archie's were there and
then you show up and did, uh,
you kind of look like,
um,
it was interesting because my first
take was this is not what I expected.
This is not what I expected
you introduced me.
I mean there was,
there was a progression
of events and next, um,
sartorial styles stylings
because when I first met him,
he was wearing a pair of golden
overalls that he would write.
He used as a notepad basically.
So if he needed to write some
his phone number down here,
just ride it cause he couldn't afford,
you know, paper. And he was living in, uh,
an unfinished basement of somebody is
unfinished basement that didn't have,
are an actual floor or walls.
So he could urinate indiscriminately
in any given corner of his lodgings.
You would do that? Well, I mean
wouldn't you? I'd use a jar.
I've been in that situation and I
couldn't afford a jar. I mean I would,
I would get,
I would get a few feet away from my bed.
Oh I wasn't so you're civilized. Yeah,
it wasn't an animal. Yeah. So it started,
that's where we,
that was the jumping off point and then
by the time we went to like a fancy
thing,
he was really like his idea of high
style was turquoise jewelry and a crazy
leather jacket. He's still,
you can tell. I still really,
that's his dream. Yeah. So yeah.
I I had actually met you. I just want
to revise. I'm just for the record,
cause I know this is going to go down
in history. I had, I had done your shot.
You had already met me.
I met as a couple the first time I
met you guys together because now
I think of you as one person. Yes.
We are wanting to become Sonny and
Cher. Yeah. Woodward and Bernstein.
Um, you know, you're, you don't
mention one without the other.
You're a peanut butter and jelly. You're
Leopold and Loeb. Look it up. Kids,
they were terrible, terrible killers.
Uh, without remorse in the 1920s,
they were executed. I mean,
right now they were not executed.
They were put in a prison for life.
One was killed in prison,
the other was released. Uh, and I
think you have the late sixties,
early seventies, moved to Puerto
Rico and died there two years later.
Why do I know that? I don't know a
lot like them. And Ken was a little,
we went down one of my warm halls,
Leopold and Loeb kids look it up.
One of the great murder stories of all
time. But there isn't time for that.
There's only time for you. Um, Megan,
we've talked a lot about your family, uh,
in private and you've asked me
never to discuss it publicly.
And this is a podcast,
so when I don't think that counts,
you describe your family and first of all,
let me compliment you on the book,
the book,
the greatest love story ever told on the
New York Times bestseller list and also
the Los Angeles Times best seller list.
Yeah, Nigga Malawi. Nick Offerman,
the greatest love story ever told to buy
it if for no other reason than just the
book jacket is the best book
jacket I have seen. I don't,
I think in memory
book jacket as well as all
the photos in the book, uh,
were the brainchild of Megan.
She art directed all of it.
It's really beautifully done and these
are great photos, fantastic photos
and they let me design the whole back,
which for me was a huge thing because I
don't usually get that kind of autonomy
on any project.
I'm just the hired help,
you have so many talents.
People can sort of almost take it for
granted that you're this great comedic
actress,
but you're also an amazing singer.
I've seen you perform many times and you
would be famous in your own right as a
singer.
Then I go to your home and you,
your first question you want to ask is
what fancy person did you get to get you
this art in this sculpture?
And you did it.
You love collecting and finding art and
you're incredibly talented at it and you
could also make it as a
top designer home design.
That's probably what I would do if I
wasn't doing all the actings and things
you think you would
really be a home designer
am almost at a certain point when I
wasn't getting a lot of work as an actor.
I am most general tried to enroll
at Ucla to study interior design.
I mean that it sort of
takes your breath away.
The Times I've been allowed in your home
and the Times I've also gone in when
you're not there, uh, it, uh,
it takes your breath away.
The other thing that takes your breath
away is I would admire the furniture and
it's absurd,
but much of it has been designed
and built by Mr Nick Offerman.
It's insane. I'll walk up to the nicest
piece of furniture in the house. Oh,
nick made that.
I haven't made anything since.
I think I had popsicle sticks and I tray
I traced my hand to make a Turkey and
then I put pop popsicle sticks over it
and recently sold at Southerby's for
$2.30.
Well, uh, it's um, it may be
immodest of me to say this,
but I think Megan's greatest
talent is her taste. She almost,
anything she puts her hand
to is astonishing. She wants
to cut our poodle's hair.
Yeah.
I cut our pills hair for years
and it was cuter than anything uh,
Pixar has ever envisioned.
Sometimes.
You know,
the thing though is I'm doggedly
determined to not educate myself in any of
these areas. Like I never studied acting.
I never, I don't know anything about art.
I just pick stuff that
I like. And then, yeah,
you know, this is infuriating
to so many people listening.
So I think it's really appealing
about both of you when I'm around you,
is that you're doing stuff that you love.
It comes out of a need.
Like you need to make things out of wood.
You need to decorate,
you need to make people laugh.
You need to sing.
Well you do too. I mean you, you know,
we need to express ourselves creatively.
I don't,
I just need desperately want the cash
and this was the best way to get it fast.
I need a lot of cash because
I made some bad mistakes.
But you said Megan,
I think you,
you described your family as very small,
mostly dead and crazy.
I mean,
my family is scattered throughout
institutions across the US.
And your dad was up like a practical joker
but not necessarily a funny practical
joker? No, he was,
I had a very dark sense of humor and for
like a couple of examples of his humor
would be he and my mom and I would be
sitting at the dinner table and then my
father would all of a sudden pretend
that he was having a massive heart attack
and then fall over. He'd
really, you know, he did commit,
I'll give him that fall over
endo has played of, you know,
spaghetti or whatever.
And the first time he did it,
my mom and I were like,
is he dead or what's going on?
And then after that we were
just kinda like, you know,
get out of the Spaghetti and
then another time I guess.
So your reaction when you thought
it was real was to just wonder, Huh?
Wonder if that's real or not? Yeah, well,
I mean I knew it was terrifying
because I was, you know,
eight so it was really scary.
I'm,
I'm downplaying it for the sake of,
you know, podcast listeners everywhere.
I don't want to try,
I want to be taken into
child services. Um, but uh,
then another thing that he did was like,
I used to take the bus.
The only year I took
the bus was third grade.
So say I was nine and I came in the door.
I didn't like being alone with my
father because he was really terrifying.
And so I came in the door and my mom's
car wasn't there and my father was
standing at the top of the
stairs and I said, where's mommy?
And he said he had this focal affectation
that he did all the time. He said,
I'm sorry to tell you this,
my and I met your mother is dead.
And I for a second I was like,
wait.
And then he said,
and then you just kind of went on.
He elaborated on how she had died
and it was like a lot of, some,
some children lose their parents at an
early age and it wasn't going to be an
easy life. And, um, and
finally I said, you know,
where is she?
And he said the grocery store.
Oh my God. Yeah. He also told me one time,
no, it wasn't cute. And he also
tell me one time when I
was in high school that um,
he'd had to go to the doctor because he
had a little skin cancer lesion or his
ear. So he had to have
it. Like Marie moved.
And I talked to him on the phone because
my parents had been separated by them
and I said, how did it go?
And he said, well, I'm sorry
to tell you this, my darling.
But they had to take the
air and I said, Oh, what?
And he goes,
yes,
I don't want to frighten your little
friends when I come by the house. And I,
I said,
I'm sorry to hear that.
And he then did not correct himself until
I saw him two weeks later and he had
two ears and I was like, and he'd
already forgotten about it by then.
Yeah. Thing is, he's clearly not
amusing you. So who is this for?
Is it just for himself?
Teeny weeny sociopathic.
A little in the cute, cute sociopath's.
Yeah. Unlike Leopold and Loeb, no kids.
I just stay true sociopath.
I need to take a quick break,
but we have so much more to talk about
now it's time for this segment.
Conan O'brien pays off the mortgage
on his beach house during that.
Why you start to laugh? It's
not funny. It's a big mortgage.
You made so many bad
decisions is a bad decision.
I think in the long run it will
end up being a good decision.
But in the short period of time right now,
I need to make some money. Okay. Okay.
Then we're going to do that right now.
Pay Down that mortgage.
Well, I kind of wanted to talk about
this new APP. It's one that, uh,
actually sounds pretty cool.
Uh,
I don't know if anyone out there is
always wanting to learn how to play a
musical instrument. I mean, who
hasn't everybody's have do we,
she played in new commencement. They
played a musical instrument. Yeah.
But I don't know how to
learn. I wish there was an
app that could teach me, well,
maybe I can help you.
There's something called using
one app that's using [inaudible].
It's a personal music tutor for
the digital age. Cool. Yeah.
So you don't even have to
hire a, a music tutor. Me.
And if I was a music tutor right now,
I'd be sweating bullets because uses
[inaudible] is going to put you out of
business. Um, wow. That's
rough. Really rough.
Yeah. Uses and teaches you. It's, I don't
know, you learn, learn from this APP.
It's free. It's very cool. Uh, you
don't have to be, uh, you know,
a beginner. You can be a beginner. You
can be experienced, you can be whatever.
You know,
it takes you through step by step
tutorials that suit your playing level.
Guess how many users
musician has 65,000 nope.
10 million.
10 million users.
10 when 10 million people make a decision,
it has to be right. That's a fact.
10 million people have occasionally
made a mistake but not with you.
[inaudible] this is a very cool app.
I like to play the guitar and
I would like to use musician.
I will use uses [inaudible] and in fact
I just revealed that I haven't yet used
it but I will use it.
Well I think you have used it cause your
personal experiences required for this
ad copy. Oh [inaudible] Oh,
I thought you meant blues.
Titian oh that's a thing. No. [inaudible]
I've used [inaudible] is great.
I use musician all the time.
[inaudible] is a great app.
It's easy to use and if you want to
learn how to play a cool song like um,
you know, let's throw a cabbage
of the Kaiser. Uh, yeah,
it was a big song in 1919,
uh,
that you can go online and
learn how to play that song.
Let's throw a cabbage at the Chi is a,
he's calming down this way.
That's a song that's going to come
back around again once wrap, uh,
fades anyway, use Ishan is
a cool app. Check it out.
Download musician for free
in your APP store today.
Get 15% off musician premium
when you use the code Conan.
Hey, you know what I was thinking about
the other day? What? How much I love, uh,
I love, uh, meet all kinds of
protein, whether it's chicken or beef,
yogurt. I eat a lot of meat, don't you?
You were just thinking about
how much you love meat. Yeah.
What all kinds of stuff could you
see my thought balloon over my head?
It was a pork chop and it
was a steak. Anyway, I love,
I love really good meat,
but it has to be good meat.
I have to know where it's been. I have
to know that it was, you know, good beef,
a hundred percent grass fed
chicken, pork. I need to know that.
And that's why I trust
the people at butcher box.
All the animals are treated very
humanely during their lifetime.
I believe I might be making this up.
All the animals die in their sleep of
old age. I don't know if that's true.
I think they do. I think they
just quietly slip away and uh,
they've had a happy life and then
you can taste that. And the flavor.
I like when I'm eating
a chicken or a beef,
I like to know that it just passed away
and it's bed surrounded by its relatives.
Okay. Each box that you get, this
is great. They send it to you.
Each box comes with at least
nine to 11 pounds of meat.
That's enough for 24 individuals
sized meals. No, it's not.
Not In my family growing up. That's
insane. Can you imagine my family,
if there was nine to 11 pounds
of meat, that's one meal. Yeah,
there were too many of you are, too many
of us anyway. My parents did that. Not me.
Uh, I've got so personal, so fast anyway.
Uh,
it's really great.
$129 a month works out to less
than $6 a meal. It's really fast.
It's convenient. So if you're interested
in, you should be. This is good stuff.
Butcher box.
New Subscribers will receive $20
off and Free Bacon Free Bacon.
I Love Bacon. Yeah, we're going to get
a dog's signing up for this free bacon,
but go ahead. What's Your
Bot dogs? They love Bacon.
Can just see pause typing in rural.
I don't want somebody that's going to
put in the Promo code a $20 off in free
bacon. Go to butcher box.com
enter the code Conan at checkout.
That's butcher box.com code Conan.
We a have to talk about our personal
experiences. It's required. Oh,
well I'm told that someone on staff
had it to Nisha. Tenicia got it. She
said the food is delicious. Yeah,
she says great and she's picky.
She's picky eater.
She is.
She is healthy and is picky
about her food and she loves it.
And she also said the bacon was a male.
Yes,
but your box from Tanya don't be
a for butcher box. Butcher box
and we're back. We didn't, we
didn't really take a break.
You just heard a lot of stuff.
I changed my clothes,
which was delicious.
I had radical face surgery.
Nick,
when I first got to know you,
I really did think this guy
comes from another time.
You are not a a man of this millennia.
I really believe that you were,
I think you I think know the past. I
think from the past. I really believe,
and I hate to know I'm supposed
to say yes and in Improv, but no,
and I really believe that you are a
very honest policemen and 1840 and um,
and woodworker who makes puppets.
And you came here into these
times to talk some sense into us.
That's the sense I get.
You're very old world.
What do you think or come by it honest? I
mean I, uh, when I got to show business,
it was interesting.
I did recognize immediately how
superficial it was an I was immediately
disinterested and I said,
okay,
I'm not going to chase
this particular brass ring.
I'm going to continue working
as a carpenter. And they
have my number. If they,
if they need a slow talking
guy to drive a bus or you know,
play a plumber, they'll find
me. And eventually, but by
dribs and drabs, you know,
the business and I came together.
But I'm in hindsight,
I'm grateful that I had that
wherewithal. I Dunno, it comes from,
I think my parents from just
having the sensibility to,
to look at it at any given
context and say, okay,
all my peers that are putting themselves
through this auditioning process,
they're all stressed out.
They're all depressed,
they're all drinking way too
much, and uh, I can do that. Sure.
And still get paid to hammer
nails. Um, and so I, I can't, uh,
I can't claim any great knowledge,
you know, of my own accord.
I think I'm just lucky
and you know, I've changed, I think
I've changed a lot since we first met.
And you've changed a
lot since we first met.
I wash myself as often as once a week now.
Yeah.
That's what the three stooges used to say.
They would crash through the floor and
all three of them would land in a bathtub
and one of them go like, but it's not
Sunday. And I always thought that was,
I didn't get that joke when I was a kid
and then later on I grew up and realized,
cause we only had to take
a bath like once a week.
But then I later on realized
that that's considered uncouth,
that you're supposed to have a
bath once or twice, you know,
every couple of days it really,
anytime you begin to stink,
oh okay. Well I should, I could do better
then. Yeah. Your step up your, again,
I'm going to tell a quick story
and I know I've told this,
recounted this to many people,
but when Megan was in Seattle
and you were doing, um,
the young Frankenstein and lies and
I were there visiting her family,
so we hung out a little bit and
we went to see you in the show,
which we absolutely loved.
You killed it.
And one day I mentioned I like
to ride bikes and Nick said,
let's ride bikes together. So the two of
us, one of those long bike turned into,
took his way south of Lake Washington and,
and then all of a sudden I heard like
a popping explosion sound and Nick's
change just exploded it, which can
happen sometimes on a bike. And I'll,
I'll say that as an experienced bikes man.
So you know,
I'm really ride bikes. It exploded in
pieces when everywhere, and now I know me,
I would have gotten off the bike
and said, oh shit, my bike blew up.
This was pre Uber or anything like that.
But I guess I just have to pick it up or
hide it in a Bush and then go walk and
find a cab. Nick gathers all the
pieces and I said, what are you doing?
And he said, well I think this
can be fixed. And then he said,
I just need a flat rock.
And I didn't know,
I thought he was doing a bit
and he didn't know you as well.
And then you went and you found a flat
rock and this is me telling exactly what
happened.
You assembled all the pieces and you
lay them out on a flat rock and then you
found another rock and you were inspected
them all and then you found the right
one and you started hammering the pieces
back together again until after about
40 minutes you had completely reassembled
the chain using prehistoric tools you
got on and then you went on your way
and when I brought it up later on,
you acted as if anyone else I would be
bragging about that for years you acted
like it was unmanly of
me to even mention it.
This is what one does when their bicycle,
when a machine breaks,
you find rocks and you fix it
and then you're on your way.
What's your problem city boy, that's
just, that's just proper comportment.
I think you could have made a,
if you needed to in that moment or radio
using using twigs and a dead rabbit and
some manure.
I think you could have made a pretty
good am FM radio that also got serious.
If you
that's it's so true. And we
seriously, for many years,
because we watched the show survivor
religiously and then to the season finales
for the last two years,
we have always said that we thought that
nick would kill on survivor for them.
So those very reasons.
Have you ever thought about that you'd
go on a celebrity survivor and you could
clean it up?
Celebrity just regular
it's been discussed. Yeah. I mean we,
we've sincerely looked
at it in reality it was
actually maybe going to happen and
then he got another, like an acting
job. Yeah. The thing of the things
that you would really do it,
you wouldn't really go on
survivor. I would love to. I mean,
I think it'd be really fun. I don't know.
I think it'd be good at some things,
but I'm not certain that I would be,
you know,
thank you.
Wouldn't be good at,
because I can't think of one
thing you wouldn't be good at.
Uh,
I,
I'm not sure how well I would fare in
the social aspect of the game because
everybody freaking all loves you.
Right. But you don't play games right.
He doesn't, he has no, he has no guidance.
Big Edit. The lying. Yeah, his brain.
He's not aft up enough to
think of how to square it.
And also you would probably say something
like you are kind of, okay, go on. Sorry.
No, no, go ahead.
One time we were staying in a hotel,
I was in Seattle and we were there for
seven or eight weeks and we had been in
this same room for the whole time and we
are moved and like we were living there
right? And they were like, oh,
but there's this one weekend where we
have to move you out of the room because
we, it's a honeymoon situation and we
promise these people like, you know,
two years ago that they could have
this year suite for the weekend.
And we were like, wait, we have
to move all over everything.
So Nick,
I'm really surprised me
with his revenge fantasies.
And the one I remember most distinctly
was moving all our stuff out and be like,
okay fine. No problem. We'll just move
into another room for the weekend.
We'll move all, pack up, all of
our belongings. It's fine. Um,
as we're doing that,
nick would some how procure
a dead to dead rats,
which she would put,
he would unscrew the heating the
event over the heating system.
Yeah.
And he would put the dead rats in there
and then screw the thing back on and
then turn the heat on
and slowly dead rats that would fill that
room described it to me in such to do,
like he'd thought it out down
to the last detail. I do that,
I think about it, but I don't do
it right. So now this my assistant,
so I just jump in for a
second. Yeah. I have a great,
I have a lot of pent up Irish rage
and I have a good imagination.
I think of great things I could, I could
do, but I never do them. Right. Right.
But a lot of them have
to do with murder too,
about how you would murder and it,
so it gets a little bit more
dark than putting rats in event,
which is also really screwed up. Sorry.
It's a good idea what you have. Sure.
I, uh, if the other day, you
know, I'm trying to watch my,
I've been trying to eat well and
uh, I've been told, you know,
you can occasionally have a
steak but has to be really lean.
Just make sure it has no sauce on.
I meant this, she, she restaurant,
it's actually more of a hipstery
restaurant and they have a stake that they
serve and it's the steak.
It's a really lean cut and it
just comes with vegetables.
And it was the perfect thing for me to
eat. And I was hungry and it says, yeah,
and we smother it in this
butter sauce. And I said, great,
I'll have that, but
just could you just, uh,
could I not have the butter sauce and
this guy in like a tweed cap wearing
suspenders with a,
with like a,
a hipstery mustache said,
no,
you have to take it the way we, and I
said, no, all I'm asking for is, you know,
the stuff that I'm not allowed to eat,
can you just not have that?
And the guy went, hey man, that's not
our scene here. You got to have it on.
And so he, I said, okay,
I'll just have the the fish then
and I said it like that and he went,
got it and walked away and I spent the
next 40 minutes doing elaborate with lies
at the table,
ways that I was going to fuck with this
guy and screw over this restaurant and
take them down and make them pay and then
ever of course every time he came over
I'm just like, oh hey. Yeah, I'm
perfectly nice left. A really nice tip.
Ate the fish I didn't want but I was,
you know, but God, I had great fantasies.
I think I was going to put his body in a
heat vent. It's, I think that's healthy.
I do a lot of revenge. Found a
sizing, most of them. Just to wrap,
just to wrap that up,
I do think then you could do well on
survivor because I think that you do have
that side of you,
which is what I started by saying,
which is that you're not just
like Super Mr. Nice all the time.
You have another side
can ask him the question.
Have you guys ever watching naked
and afraid? Could you do nick,
could you go on? Could either of you
go on naked and afraid? Wait a minute.
You're in the woods with coyotes and
butterflies watching you doing it?
Like animals, like bugs
crawling up your badge. No,
no.
The vantage bugs are definitely,
we're going to look in the car. I
didn't know. You know what I have to,
I have a book of insects at home.
I will look up the Vage bug.
I'm not familiar with it.
Are not down with,
there's some things
that I love watching it.
I think those people
deserve like commit it.
They're like hardcore
survival survival us. Yeah,
but it's a really weird I,
the thing that I can't do is
I grew up in the east coast.
I spent a lot of time traipsing around
the woods and stuff and I was sent off to
camp bugs. It's the thing I love
about Los Angeles. There's no box.
There's no bugs. Seemed to be no bags
anywhere, right? Yes. For frankly,
I can't wait if that's
the price we pay for it,
if it means global warming
and the extinction of our
species all, I'm all for it,
but, but I don't like the
bugs in our naked and afraid.
The idea of being naked and
being constantly attacked
by bugs, all manner of,
of uncertainty I would
like about it is you know,
learning all the crazy tricks that they
have to like build shelters and you
know, they magically can kind
of solve any problem with their,
the wherewithal that they've garnered
over the years is survivalists.
I find that fascinating,
but they're naked.
It's so fun and afraid and afraid
and I'm always afraid when I'm naked.
It's very, it is actually,
you're afraid to be me naked.
I want to be on the show.
Afraid to be naked.
She just huddled in a corner and
refuse to take up your clothes.
You're not even in the wild.
You're in your comfortable home.
You're in your bedroom and my
bedroom and I'm fully clothed,
but the producers off cameras
sync, please. You've got
to take off your clothes,
and I'm desperately trying,
but at the end I always,
when hundreds of thousands
of dollars a month,
you naked with a naked
woman who wasn't me.
You had not.
Nick is the most,
he's the least likely man that I ever
have known to not ever even look at
another woman. It's kind
of, it's so strange,
man. Who wouldn't not.
So I don't know how that,
I have no idea what nick around a
naked woman who's not you. What?
Nick would be incredibly embarrassed
and wouldn't know what to do or where to
put his eyeballs are a three piece suit
out of Cherry Wood.
Beautiful Mahogany.
He's not a cheater or he's not.
He doesn't ever even look at.
It's weird.
Look at other women doesn't do that.
That's nice.
I think I would overcompensate
in some way I would try to,
do you know what I mean?
I do a lot of shtick about them
being naked and me being naked,
but all the while just humiliating myself.
I think it's best that I
not go on naked and afraid.
Do not go on naked and afraid. I think so.
I think none of us are going on it now.
It's out. I've been
invited. Here's the thing,
here's really what it comes down to.
Megan and I have a two week rule.
Whenever apart for more than two weeks,
I'm suspending it for this
cause I really want to watch it.
When you go on survivor, whether you're
the first person kicked off or the,
the the winner,
everyone has to stay for
six weeks because you can't,
the world's can't know who
goes home, goes home. So if
they wouldn't let me visit him,
he got kicked off after four weeks.
But you know what, you could,
I mean, first of all lies.
And I would come and stay at your place.
I love your house. We'd stay there.
You don't seem thrilled, but
I'm, I am thrilled. This is,
no, that's not what I'm getting at
all. And I read faces. But anyway,
I would make it my business to be
around and protecting you and uh,
being a good friend to you and you, uh,
you wouldn't even miss this guy. Oh,
you'd be so many laughs.
So many good times for survivor is such
that this would be the one and only
exception I would make
to our two week rule.
And I read it and I'd have my
wife and I have a two week rule,
but ours is every two weeks.
She wants me to go away for eight weeks
capitalist. It's a little
different than what you guys do,
but it's kept us together. That's good.
I'm, I'm glad that you would suspend that.
I would have allowed that.
You would do that if we did that
and I agreed to it. Uh, there's
uh, there's eventually on the show,
um,
late in the game weeks in,
they bring in loved ones of
the contestants and quite
often when the loved one
is revealed and they,
they run in class with each other,
it could be a spouse or a
parent or a sibling. They,
there's a lot of sobbing and an
incredible emotional upheaval.
I would fall on the ground and
cry my eyes out because I don't,
I dunno if I could be away
from you for six weeks.
That's a really sweet moment.
Start making love to coconuts,
which you could probably fashion so
that it's probably more pleasurable.
Well listen, I've done a little
reading on this and if you're gonna,
if you're gonna make love to
a Mellon Mellon's in his past,
let's just leave it at that.
Obviously you need to bore a hole,
but the thing you might not realize
is you want to champ for it though.
That's my question.
I'm guessing hopefully your pocket knife.
So what would you do to the whole,
you gotta know you got a Chamfer,
the edge of that whole cause there Ryan
is sharp and it will really chafe. Yes.
This is just something I've read up on
and if it's a cantaloupe and you can warm
it up for a couple of minutes,
how you do that microwave won't be sorry.
A couple of minutes in the microwave.
And then you've got chamfered
edges and then do you,
how long can you keep them knowing around?
Come on last. Well can you
draw this for me? Yeah, I can.
I mean there, it's kind of
a one. I'm about to hit the
road. I'm just about to go.
Do a tour and I'm going
to be alone. Yeah. Yeah.
It's kind of despoiled
well travel with
um,
this took a turn and you know what?
Mostly usually I would say I didn't expect
that but when you to for the melon is
very touching.
We are both,
we are gentlemen and we are chivalrous and
uh, you know, treat that melon. Wow.
The point is I would
say to any other guests,
I didn't see it going this
way when you walked in.
Only I did see it going in this way when
both of you walked in because you are a
sex depraved animalistic.
Sensualists yeah,
I think nothing, uh, you know
ravish each other nightly and uh,
it sickens me. I think it's wrong. I
think it's evil. No, that's your problem.
Okay.
Get it on. But yeah, you know what,
you two are welcome to do it here.
No one can see you.
There'll be some sounds in the background,
but I can hum to cover those sounds.
Can you see him from where you are?
Cause yeah, you look really
handsome. Yeah, you did really good.
Hang on. Did you have some work
done? Uh, he, uh, I got work done.
I wish I'd paid more for it. I like
cheap. Oh, well then it looks, I mean,
you get what you pay for.
That's the problem.
It's a place that said you're
in and out in an hour and yeah,
they don't use anesthesia and
they say they do take, uh,
they take bonded checks. And
uh, so I went there and I said,
just let's pull back the cheeks.
And it got infected.
An old melons.
Exactly.
They sack over your shoulder to shoulder.
I've used melon. Is that what you said?
Yeah,
if they'd been despoiled by a celebrity
that you can actually sell them on Ebay.
Do you want it? We want some
melon. A melon that nick Offerman.
Fuck.
And then you watch the bidding go crazy.
Uh, I apologize to
everyone. All right Nigga.
Mohali Nick Offerman, there's
no greater couple, uh,
in the history of the world. We
wish you all the best. Bye. Bye.
Thank you.
And now it's time for a segment called
Conan O'Brien pays off the mortgage on
his beach house.
I built my life around my hair. You did.
You know what I mean? It's a trademark.
It's a trademark. I started, you know,
my hair is a big part of my confidence,
my personality.
If I lost my hair tomorrow,
I'd I quickly buy like an old Lucille
ball wig and put it on from the Lucille
ball state. Okay. No one would notice.
No, probably not. It would look the same.
But so Harris say it's
important to people's confidence
to their sense of self.
And um, that's why I uh, I was
going to mention hair club.
Hair club's the leader in
total hair solutions. You know,
they have a legacy of
success for over 40 years.
Who's been in the hair business
for 40 years? Yeah, I know buddy.
I remember those commercials from
when I was young. Hair club. Yeah.
I'm not just a member. I'm the
president. Right. Sy Sperling. Just him.
Is that who it was? I think it
was, I don't think we're probably,
he's not here on the ad copy, so maybe
we're not supposed to mention him anymore.
Oh, I'm sorry. And who even
knows if this is the same either.
They'd been bought out in CISE Berlin is,
maybe there's legal stuff.
Who even knows we've wandered into a
total weird area here. I'm sorry. I, yeah,
I didn't expect you to
know that guy. Ah, yeah,
I remember those commercials really well.
I wrote to his fan club.
I ended up hanging out with them.
Uh,
I was a groupie in the sites of early
gang for a while. It's cool. Anyway,
you know,
people that are looking to regrow hair
or revitalize their hair if they got any
kind of hair problem. It sounds to me
like hair clubs, the place for you,
don't you think? No, I don't have personal
experience with losing all my hair.
But it could happen at any time. Yeah.
You're a guy. Guys lose their hair.
You know what?
Not if they have a low testosterone that's
a guys with high testosterone tend to
lose all their hair. I was very
wisely opted for low testosterone.
You opted for low testosterone. Yes. Done.
Everything I could to keep my testosterone
is low as possible in my life so that
I can hang onto my hair.
Um, you did it. I did it.
I kept my hair and my voice
still hasn't dropped. But anyway,
why dwell on the negative when
I should? Well, on the positive,
if I were to lose my hair, I'd go
to hair club. I really would, um,
or just leave the country.
But anyway,
they seem to know what
they're talking about.
They've been in the business
longer than anybody.
And we know women lose their hair too.
That's true. It's not just for men.
That's right. It isn't just for
men. If women lose their hair also,
you don't think of women losing
their hair, but uh, but they do,
they do lose their hair as well.
It happens more to men
because of the testosterone.
But that's why it's less frequent
for women or people like me with low
testosterone to lose their hair.
Your group did with women? No.
Let's just let that go.
So if you're struggling with hair loss,
if that's a problem for you, go to a
hair club. Maybe they're the solution,
you know,
give him a shot.
Go to hair club.com/conan today for a
free hair analysis and a free take home
hair care kit. What do you think
is in that? The haircare kit?
I have no problems with my hair,
but I want the hair care kit all
valued at over $300 creams, lotions,
bombs, emollients, various oils, resins.
Do you think there are any resins
in their syrup's and serums?
Okay. How about various, uh,
emulsions and emollients?
That's hair club.com/conan for a free
hair analysis and free hair care kit.
I've got to get that hair care kit here.
club.com/conan hair club.com/conan.
I'll be saying it in my sleep.
This is Matt.
I believe in the beginning you said you
might be ambivalent and you were a bit
more positive after this conversation.
What are the prospects of continuing
this friendship? Do you think
we were
justing when we said ambivalent and
by we, I mean nick. That's right.
And we love Conan.
I mean Matt Madly.
And so I think everything has had
a very, very, very happy beginning,
middle, and end. Very nice.
I noticed you two were holding
hands almost the entire time too.
That was very heartwarming. We like each
other. It's a habit. It's a nice habit.
Yeah. If you could hold
hands with her, wouldn't you?
I sure of what that was like a like a
kind of [inaudible] sort of reaching.
That was very sweet. Thank you guys for
doing this. Thank you so much. Thank you.
Oh,
so Conan. I always do that.
You know I'm in the room.
I'm sitting eight inches from you.
You acted like you were in a well and
you fell into the darkness and you're
wondering if I'm out there somewhere
and right here. Okay. Conan. Yeah.
The reviews are in for this podcast
we're doing. We're doing well.
We're doing well here. Your podcast
has five star ratings, which is great.
Five star out of how many stars out of
five I didn't know that was out of five.
Yeah, I thought that was out of 10 that's
exactly where my mind goes. Oh, okay.
That's just the way I've been raided by
most people in relationships that I've
been in. Five out of five. That's,
that's cool. Yeah. Okay. So far so good.
That's great. That's great.
What's, what are the,
what are the people out there thinking?
I want to know what they're thinking.
Well, we're going to read some
reviews. Okay. All right. So I'm gonna,
I'm gonna read some, yeah, yeah.
Keep saying you're going to do it.
But if you were a pitcher in
baseball and you're on the mine,
you're like gonna Pitch Pretty soon. Gun
to pitch the ball gun, a pitch the ball.
And you never did a Nav.
Omar give you five stars and
their review is, it's not bad.
What? Yeah, it's not bad. And he's,
and he gave me five stars out of five.
Yes.
So wait,
that guy goes in to an RBS and has a
perfectly mediocre sandwich and says,
Eh, it was edible. Five
out of five. He's, man,
he's just handing out FiveStars
left and right. Not Bad.
How about life changing? So the
FiveStars is FiveStars is there. Well,
if you're going to write
something after five stars, right?
I now see what life is all about. Thank
you. Thank you. Conan. Don't right.
Not Bad. What? Sue, sue, ed, Sua dubs.
Sue dubbs. No, sue dubs.
I was reading that wrong.
Sue Dubs said your podcast makes me
want to give you a hug. Oh, it's sweet.
Is it though or is it that
she feels sorry for me?
It could be she feels sorry
for you. It could be, oh,
I listened to him and I
just want to give him a hug.
But I will also say when I was single,
pity was the motivating force
behind most of the women.
They had hooked up with me.
So pity is my friend. I think
she may pity me, but that's okay.
It doesn't matter. That's
something to brag about. Pity.
Pity was pity was my wing man.
That should be the name
of my autobiography.
Pity was my wing man by Conan O'brien.
I would, I'd like to hug her as well.
As long as it was all monitored
and was done. Um, you know,
appropriately it can match what?
Achy. Madge, icky, Madge I,
these are all screaming what's
going on? He can match, right?
He's a ginger. Gingers are people
too. Dot. Dot. Dot. Question Mark.
Oh my God,
this is brutal.
And we're a very well reviewed podcast
and these are the happy comments.
Yeah, I'm a ginger. All right.
And Ginger are people to Ginger's
I should have made that plural.
It ginger are people do, apparently
we're not, we can't even speak correctly.
Uh, yes. You know gingers are,
we are the one group that everyone
feels comfortable making fun of.
You know what I mean?
Like it,
think about it in this age
of extreme sensitivity.
You couldn't make that comment about any
other kind of person by the freckles.
Why would you focus on those? I
have a lot of freckles. You know,
a lot of them don't show up on camera on
TV. Of course they put makeup on. But,
um, my hands have a ton of
freckles. My, my hands look, uh,
they just look crazy.
They've got so many, right?
You've seen my hands when I come
back from like a Caribbean island,
I looked like a mummy that just
crawled it's way out of the tomb.
I was surprised when I met you
for the first time. Oh my God.
It speaks quarterly.
What are you talking about?
You were surprised the amount of freckles.
You didn't think I'd have that many
know. What else surprised you? Be Honest.
Guide the hightest. Uh, people
don't think I'm not tall.
Your presence is commanding.
Thank you. You're welcome. Oh,
you can't see this right now. But Gourley
is saluting me. Uh, he is saluting me, uh,
the way they do in the navy. Uh, so that,
so really seriously my height and then
freckles on my face or just in general.
I'm only joking, but yeah, you don't
see them on TV. You don't see him on TV.
They're actually becoming cause it,
it kind of, it's a part of you. Yes.
It makes me more human. They look good.
Well thank you. Yeah. Let me take it easy,
pal. Yeah, I'll back off now. Yeah,
I'll cut this. No, no, no. I like this.
You want me to keep the one positive
thing we've really heard about me. Oh,
but three stars. Sorry. Yeah,
I get growly when he met me,
gave me three stars from my
physical appearance, but he
does like the podcast, so,
and he got that going. It was nice to him
to be cut in and say, that was nice. I,
I hope he doesn't cut that out or I
don't know. You don't care. I know.
I don't know. Read another one. Let's
keep the sound. All right. Let's,
do you have trouble reading? No,
I'm just trying to choose ones. Oh,
by Matt. Matt. Matt. To
near the end of life.
It's important to record your voice
so that the family can listen back and
remember you fondly.
You think some at the end
of my life, maybe he knows
something that I don't know.
Eerie. Isn't that eerie? I
won't see. Think I am. I'm
not that old. What was that?
Some kind of veiled threat?
I hope so. You hope so. Yeah.
It gets my name in the papers.
You know,
the important thing is I always say that
when I don't know what I'm saying. Next
important thing is I do believe he's
correct that the recorded voice is
important and I'm going to
say something else. Hmm.
This is me just freewheeling here.
People's last words used to be very
important and they talked about it a lot.
Do you know like with one of the
founding fathers was on his deathbed,
he'd say the republic still stands
and then he would die. You know?
Is that real? Did someone say that?
I think people said things like that.
People used to say things like,
and now I go to my rest
and then they would die.
Stonewall Jackson famously
when he was mortally wounded,
his last words were take me over
the river and into the trees. Oh,
beautiful. And then he passed
away and I was thinking about it.
There aren't last words anymore because
they keep us going forever and we're all
hooked up. We have tubes in
our mouth and stuff at the end.
So when I last words are like, Oh, oh,
do you know what I mean? I mean,
I'm not trying to be funny.
I'm not trying to make you laugh.
You know,
Picasso wasn't always
trying to make great art.
Sometimes he was just
scribbling on a Napkin.
But my point is that there are no last
words anymore because someone probably
says something really profound.
Like one of my time comes,
I'm going to try and say
something profound and I'm
going to say something like,
and now let us to the other
world and to the light,
but then a nurse is going
to come in and go, nope,
we can keep him going for another year
and inject all this shit into me and then
jam a tube in my throat and then
I got to spend a year going. Yeah.
Oh,
they're going to say,
what were his last words?
He said something kind of profound
a year ago. We'll wait. We'll wait.
What was that? I don't remember.
It was a year ago. What did he say?
Just before he died?
Well,
those were his last words.
I think something's been lost.
Yeah.
No.
Brian needs a friend with sona most
Sassy and Conan O'brien as himself,
produced by me,
Matt Gorley,
executive produced by Adam Sachs and Jeff
Ross at Team Coco and Collin Anderson
and Chris Mann and add your wharf special
thanks to Jack White and the white
stripes for the theme song
incidental music by Jimmy Vivino.
You can rate and review this show on
podcasts and you might find your review
featured on a future episode.
Got a question for Conan and call the
team coco hotline at (323) 451-2821 and
leave a message in.
Could be featured on a future
episode and if you haven't already,
please subscribe to Conan O'brien. Needs
a friend on apple podcasts, stitcher
or wherever fine podcasts are down.
This has been cocoa production
in association with,
Hey, this is Arnie from the comedy
podcasts. Hello from the magic tavern,
a chat show I host from the magical land
of food with my cohost use at all the
blue wizard and chuck the shape shifter
most weeks we interview adventurers,
ambulatory trees.
We have a special episode.
I am so excited to learn about the earth
law contained in pride and prejudice.
We're going to do a book
club up pride and prejudice,
and you said this is a world
of book on Earth, right? Yeah.
It's one of those books that people love
or were forced to read or more likely.
It's one of those I'm going to get to,
it's and some of our most
beloved of guests are a
churning to read the book with
us and enjoy some drinks and food. Have a
book club. We are flower. We have chrome,
the barbarian and girl.
You know who they are.
Maybe you don't give a crap about what
an academic thinks about Jane Austin,
but don't you want to know what a
wizard and a badge or think about it.
Not enough spells, not enough
grubs, not enough sword fights.
Whether you love pride and prejudice or
have no interest in reading it and just
want to listen to a book club
going really off the rails.
You'll enjoy this week's hello from
the magic tavern. We shall defeat.